a sequence is defined recursively as
follows so a sub n is equal to a sub n
minus 1 times a sub n minus 2 or another
way of thinking about it the nth term is
equal to the n minus 1 term times the n
minus 2 n minus 2 term with this with
the 0th term or a sub 0 is equal to 2
and a sub 1 is equal to 3 find a sub 4
so let's start this down so they're
telling us a sub 0 is equal to 2 and
they also tell us that a sub 1 is equal
to 3 so they've kind of given us our
starting conditions our base conditions
now we can think about now we can think
think about what a sub 2 is and they
tell us that a sub 2 is going to be a
sub 2 minus 1 so that's a sub 1 it's a
sub 1 times a sub 2 minus 2 that's a sub
0 so a times a sub 0 and there they told
us what a sub 1 + a sub 0 is this thing
is 3
this thing is 2 so it's 3 times 2 which
is equal to 6 which is equal to 6 now
let's move on to a sub 3 so a sub 3 is
going to be the product of the previous
two terms so it's going to be a sub 2 3
minus 1 is 2 3 minus 2 is 1 so it's a
sub 2 a sub 2 times a sub 1 times a sub
1 so it's equal to 6 times 3 6 times 3
which is equal to 18 which is equal to
18 and then finally a sub 4 which I will
do in a color that I'll use it I'll do
it in yellow a sub 4 is going to be
equal to a sub 3 a sub 3 times a sub 2
so 4 notice 4 minus 1 is 3 4 minus 2 is
2 so times a sub 2 times a within that
blue color times a sub 2 which is equal
to 18 18 times 6 18 times
which is equal to let's see 6 times 8 is
48 plus 60 is or 6 times 10 is 100 108
and we're done a sub four is equal to
100 is equal to 108